eSports isn't just a fad it's a massive
cultural phenomenon set to take over the
world with a new generation of athletes
battling in virtual worlds created using
advanced computing technology and it
takes a supercomputer to really make
this lifelike game environment exist
many textures the hair effect of wind
how water moves all of these things are
being physically modeled at a speed that
feels very real and they're doing that
with technology and they're doing that
in cooperation with us at Villa Packard
Enterprise my earliest programming
experiences were literally solving
tic-tac-toe style games on personal
computers back in the Ayden's now I'm
building some of the world's most
powerful supercomputers to take on some
of the world's most grand scientific
problems in a computational way
[Music]
supercomputers are used in all kinds of
applications today based on this very
simple idea of modeling and simulation
when we don't understand something
physically it helps us to build a model
of it and we do that in software now
first we develop the physical
characteristics of the object and then
we act on it with forces to simulate
real-world phenomena so you can think of
pushing on the object and does it
compress does it crush how does it move
how fast how does it interact with its
surroundings we use them to forecast the
weather we use them to predict where the
stock market is going we use them to
design cars and airplanes
I don't think folks understand that
behind all that is supervision
[Music]
gaming technology relies heavily on
graphical processing or GPUs instead of
CPUs GPUs use a divide and conquer
approach to data we use those same GPUs
now in supercomputing to solve
mathematical equations fundamentally
what this will allow us to do is build
larger more powerful supercomputers an
individual chip today and then perform a
trillion mathematical equations per
second
a trillion there's no end to the
capabilities of the human race to make
advances through mathematical
simulations that's what excites me to be
able to see the advancements that that
twelve-year-old kid couldn't have
imagined on today anything's possible
[Music]
you
[Music]